in the state's manual for districts
um
on how they
track especially costs and what they
need to submit to
Market there's actually two worksheets
on calculating especially a
and I found it very interesting so it
was a present
formula
so there's an example here on this
example the estimated State average
expensive with people at this time was
just under twenty thousand dollars
Rosa
[Music]
so if you multiply between 20 000
three times three and a half I'm sorry
okay
it comes out to just under seventy
thousand dollars that's the special
education in cap
that was that student's clause
um
so
to put it more concise when you go
through the rest of the worksheet
for this particular student the distance
responsibility comes out against you
so it's
the state is not paying anywhere near
us wherever the student goes if their
education
I support this building because I think
we're much more Equitable or whether you
are unhapple in town or
not as a well-funded town
a special ed doesn't have any benefits
foreign
one of the issues
that we're dealing with of course
there'll be no appropriation for this
we've the budget we've already completed
so
hello
hey you found your what was lunch good
but here it's good to see you did you
get my message yeah I did
try and read our rules here on this
um
absolutely
so just carry a little further one of
the other things that we should know is
right now in the coming formal of the
way it's part of it exists the state
pays 3 300
in a differentiated key
for students discussion
so we're acknowledging that it is
they should pay professionally
but they're not paying anymore
okay now what we are doing is uh in in
uh yes sir
um we're looking at 577 and if you
recall that dropped it from three and a
half to it's the special ed age
um
just as a side note we do I did have
communication from representative Heath
that she's putting in legislation
for the formation of a commission that
would be also funded up to 150 000 for
support
to look at the entire package of funding
this area of special education along
with a differentiated Aid component
amount and trying to come up because she
she sees it the same what I do is that
we've had this issue come before so many
times before
and there's a number of issues like
we're talking about spreadsheets just
now what would it cost if we dropped it
from three and a half to one and a half
or two two and a half and what would be
the implications for how much we have to
appropriate from the state
um we don't have that information
and when I talked to Caitlin in the past
she said it'd be more expensive of
course for the state in the cad aid but
you're splitting that money up amongst
more kids now
because you're reducing from three and a
they're being paid by local appropriated
dollars
yes
and some differentiated Aid
everybody gets differentiated if you
have an IEP
which is minimal
twenty one hundred dollars twenty three
so what I'm basically suggesting because
we only have
a month
and
we're we're not going to get any dollar
appropriation from the finance anyways
on this and I understand I was trying to
look in and there's some reference and
rules that
well I I thought I'd read somewhere
somewhere and I'm trying to find out if
it had a fiscal note
that
so
can we
uh
approach doe required doe to provide us
some numbers they have the data they
they need to make it available to us
they have to have it they require the
hi I'm Rebecca fredenham the state
director of special ed
um so we did submit a fiscal note on
this and the reason that we um said that
it was indeterminable is the only data
we collect is when the district knows
that a student is going to go over cap
so they're not going to put in a kid
um a kid's expenses that are less than
cap because they're not going to get any
money from it and they have to upload
into our system in order to be
reimbursed so they'll only put in the
invoices for a student if they know that
it's going to go up over that cap amount
so we don't collect all the expenses for
thank you
um and welcome and that's not how I had
understood it so hence my baffled face
um
but districts have to track all their
special ed expenses correct
they should be tracking all of their
special ed expenses yes they may not
necessarily track it individually per
child they may say I oops sorry I paid
for a speech-language pathologist at
this amount for the year and it was for
these 10 kids I don't know if they
necessarily would break it down into
each child we spent this much money on
so they could have
an average number per special ed student
in their District
our students that have not met the cat
yes yes one of the directors in the back
but that's not provided to doe no
because we don't we wouldn't use that
currently we don't use that for anything
so all we would use are the funds that
they're requesting from us to pay them
for special education Aid or court
so
how would we know
what
the collective we both local and State
are investing in Special Ed
too
you're not from the doe but she is from
so I don't know this but I'm wondering
if you can get it from the doe 25 that
the districts submit to
yeah so you wouldn't have it by student
oh I'm sorry Lisa Moody um I'm with the
office of finance and data so I overseas
special education Aid and court ordered
payments
um
so
what's what's Caitlyn's group division
of educational and analytics and
statistics so they get the doe 25 so
they'll be able to collect that
information but it would be their
special education costs for all students
that are in their District not just one
student
but that would give you a total
you'd be able to get a total cost of
special education for the state well
that's really what we're looking for we
don't need it everybody correct me if
you think otherwise we don't need it per
thank you
no because it's the state average I
think it is the total amount divided by
the number of students right we need the
number of students yes we need a number
of students
right
looking averages
I believe you had said that you had the
average at 32 000. that's what I yeah
yesterday and you guys can certainly
amend that I think that there's such a
um there's such a disparity in the level
of services that are provided you're
providing maybe two speech services a
week all the way up to a residential
placement with speech and OT and PT and
swallow studies and like there's a huge
disparity so it comes out to thirty
thousand thirty two thousand dollars a
year so that's why why it's I think it's
more helpful if you had it individually
because we could say okay all of these
kids would now qualify whereas we we are
saying only these kids qualify for
special education Aid but because
there's such a range of services it's
hard to say like that average isn't
going to help us I don't think
that's why we need what we had last year
right because that would
that would deal with that some somewhat
but not completely I mean there's you
could have a student who has speech and
language services but they're also
identified with autism they're
identified with other health impairment
there so it it every it's every kid is
individual and really those numbers are
based on the services that they receive
because it just adds up as you add more
services
um just preferred uh assistant
superintendent from SAU 53 the Pembroke
area schools I think something to
consider if you talk about delineating
cost per disability area you run the
risk of some discrimination factors in
there too
um so just caution that
um and I can say that you know just from
thinking of the kids that we have in our
own District you know we've got a
student that may be deaf or visually
impaired that is costing five times as
much as a student who's intellectually
impaired so I think to generalize those
categories of disability may be pretty
misleading
we do know there's a number of states
with weighted amounts per disability
that is part of their formula and we've
gone through and acquired that
information that's why we did bring
forward that uh Bill last year which did
have two two categories that's all we
had in there uh three and one in ten IEP
categories in the other and passed out
of here with a unanimous vote and went
on to finance due to the cost it cost
about 15 million dollars more with this
and we weren't really jacking up those
costs a whole lot in conjunction with
actual cost it would have cost to
provide the services for a child that
had TBI or a child in need an orthopedic
support or a child that had a disability
which was significantly more than just
the old resource room for 30 minutes a
day type thing or or even speech where
it's you know a group of five kids
getting together in in second grade and
sitting there for two times a week at 30
minutes per time learning their R's or
what have you so we know we can do that
the concern I think the the hardest
thing to do though is to get a grasp on
this
this guilt catastrophic Aid category
because a lot of these kids are coming
some of these kids come in during the
course year and you're not even ready
for that
and all of a sudden your small District
of 67 kids having to pop in on you like
Piermont had at 250 000 plus per child
you take the formula and they're still
in the ropes for a lot of money which
they don't have a trust fund or
something set up in the sorrow Reserve
set up for that like some of the larger
districts do have uh so in knowing this
this is why I representative Heath and I
and she's putting this in she's the
prime sponsor of this legislation that's
been submitted there's LSR number now
for it to set up a commission to really
take a deep dive into how we're funding
special education services there's also
an appropriation in that commission bill
that she's putting forward for support
Personnel to help us in that endeavor
um which I think is a great idea
um because we know that we're struggling
and if there's any one issue we hear
more from school districts it's that of
how do I pay for my special education
costs it's dragging money from other
areas my budget to support this one and
that's that's not good and it's really
coming down where I think uh 91a issue
it's an unfunded mandate that's coming
out those we know it's Federal so we
can't get away but the federal part is
no longer being funded
28 aches 91 that's personal privacy
confidence 28a excuse me but uh yeah the
feds are way below their 40 initial
offerings was even at less than half of
that now we're receiving
but we're still required to do idea
so I I think Mary's got a good idea here
we need to have in a committee like this
studying for
three weeks four weeks I don't think
we're going to come up with a
all the information to make a decent
decision as we would do it through a
commission study
yeah
what else last night and I thought today
uh
I thought today we were going to have
the down doe on January 31st so it
retained at the executive session to
find about paid costs
you know we had to deal with
um but I have concerned a lot of the
Peaks uh Bill not for the commission
aspect of it but rather it's just
keeping this issue down the road
this legislature has in the past recent
history
unfunded expensive items that they did
not know the cost
they they found me a hundred thousand
dollars a million though so they have
the capacity and the willingness to help
education in their perspective
this is no more this is more important
than likely for little small thoughts
are you talking about people
when these cash property folks come to
the door they advise a section of the
year they have no option and I
understand the federal mandate about the
40 we haven't got that we haven't got to
ask it down mistake I got all that
but this is a chance we have to step up
and say you know what
we're trying to help the school district
and the youngsters who in need in the
school district is actually the property
taxpayers they won't really throw the
taxpayer I'm concerned about the school
district has a full because they the
only one they have and I I have
and I I think I don't know if if it was
it withhold for me or you or or the
chair or the scenic seated Democrat know
they're supposed to ask doe so we said
this last January 31st we're going to
ask for these spots and they're going to
provide some recommendation
now because certainly sitting here
saying well we're gonna kicked down the
road at the whole cycle we made the
commission that comes through
well it is going to go for another at
least two years we we are just approved
a budget and we've appropriated X number
of dollars for I I don't know what that
amount was 30 something million 32 32
million somewhere around that
neighborhood
and that's appropriated now we drop it
down to one and a half
you're going to have more kids
qualifying for that pot of money correct
so it's going to be distributed that
limited amount of money is no longer
going to be distributed to the the ones
three and a half to ten times it's going
to be one and a half
upwards yeah so it's less money per
pupil
I'm not suggesting Rick that we that we
um Mr chair I'm not suggesting that we
diminish the three and a half to one and
a half
I'm suggesting we allow we categorize
and allow one and a half to be the
number and that's the number the state
is responsible to find
money we yeah
this is not the first time we had budget
items of money not set aside that the
state found in general funds if this
passes is their responsibility to find
it let downstairs let the corner off and
somebody else find it the money's there
we have about revenue revenue I'm
talking about this you know I I come
from a town that's not as small as some
of your folks towns and it still hits us
but this this is this is a a a a base of
a big foundation and I'm concerned that
we just
I mean I've been in three years in
education and I've heard every time in
New Hampshire I hear about the castle
obligated every and moans about
it but he had the chance to do something
about it and we've been waiting and I'm
concerned about honestly about kicking
it down the road again and maybe you're
talking out of sorts but it doesn't
bother me I think we should
take some action as As
you move forward it's an important this
is an important piece it's an important
piece with for all the small towns in
New Hampshire which there are many
somewhere in these rules as the
recommendations we can make in this sex
session coming up
passing another money Bill I don't think
we're allowed to do that
I'm gonna is there
hold on sure sure I I mean there's
there's plenty of bills that have FMS on
them that we will see
this coming year
so so uh so I don't think that's the
Restriction but and I'm sorry I was a
few minutes late but was there a um was
was there an amount a dollar amount that
um
that's been presented that that that
sort of sums up what's between one and a
they can't have they don't have that
information okay I didn't hear that I'm
sorry so and that's the point so we
don't have it but and then the mayor
under they were legitimate why they
didn't because the eye collecting that
data which makes sense you know it'll
click today I can't guess this is a way
back nicely known since January 31st
that that data wasn't collected because
we want to know the phase of this but
this is a retained bill right it's going
to come back up and and it's it's a it's
a policy bill
so so you know not to not to you know
put um put Precision over accuracy but
um but could we get an idea from the
Department you know sort of finger in
the wind what we think the differences
between one and a half times the the
average per people cost and the um the
the full cost of um of special education
so we can have a better understanding
about how much this is how much of this
is being borne by the um uh local
property taxpayer
So currently um for special education
Aid as you said it's 32 million um we're
just over 32 million this year in our
calculations and that's only 700 kids so
if you change that number to one and a
half you're you're I would I would
estimate that you're more than tripling
that number of students um I can't say
how much how much more but if you're
saying that the cost per pupil is only
going to go your cap is only going to go
to one and a half times
you're you're including a lot of kids
that are in in your schools and are
participating and they're receiving
services in your schools which currently
they are not participating in the
special education Aid pot that we
provide
um so I would say that at least three
and a half times more students probably
a lot more than that I'm I'm going low
on my estimate okay so so so just to
just to sort of you know uh you get an
idea and this is again this just finger
in the wind So So currently we're
spending 30 it's 32 million dollars
which are essentially the 20 plus the
10x group yep
um uh 20 above three and a half and then
100 above 10x and but 100 above one and
a half times could be in the 200 250
yes because you have to think we have 30
000 in special education students and
we're only covering 750 of them
approximately with that special
education Aid so you're yeah it's going
to go up drastically because you're
going to come we're going to cover a lot
more students
um I would say you know you would cover
and right now they're total cost of like
82 million for all students right for
the qualifiers for special education
their total costs come to 82 million for
the for the students that would
currently qualify for for or or where
districts are getting some relief
through the special education uh Aid
okay
foreign
I'm not sure I got this right or not
so you I believe you said special at
eight now is 32 million for just over
700 students obviously those are the
and you as representative Luna said
finger in the Wind
think three and a half times more
students than that at least if we change
to this formula at least yes
would it be correct to
[Music]
um to understand that
those students are less expensive per
there's just so many variables here we
unless we were able to get all of the
data from each district but as I said I
don't know if you track it by individual
student
because the only ones they're tracking
individually are the ones they know they
can get money from us to help them out
with their bills so they would track
their special education Aid students
they would track their court order
replacement students but other students
there's I think maybe one or two
districts that track all of their kids
to determine I think that's right if
they can get special education aid for
some of their other students I could be
wrong Jess could speak to that but um
I I think it would be a harder number to
them not we do not track individual
costs for every single student
um I have gone through and tracked all
of our districts costs as a whole so
I've gone through and said all right we
have
52 students in this one school that that
are qualifying for special education
here are all the related service
Personnel here all the special Educators
and here's how much that total is here's
the average cost per student for that
school but to break it down you'd I'd
have to go through every single IEP
calculate the hours calculate the
minutes and then calculate that based on
the salaries per individual so we don't
track the individual student costs but
the group as a whole we do I do anything
would you or that inspire you any of the
three of you
would you know how frequently districts
do the aggregate accounting that you've
um I don't think I could speak to all of
them I know I did it because I was
concerned about the cost of our special
education programs
um so I wanted to know on average how
much each building was spending on
special education and if there were huge
influxes why
um and really it was our at a district
costs that spurred those conversations
so it wasn't even like the school-based
programming that spurred me to do that
it was the cost that we're spending for
our out of District costs that's what
spurred me to do that because I wanted
to make sure
we were over spending in one building
and then under spending in another
building and what the reason would be
for those things
um I can tell you that
a big portion of our costs are
transportation
it's not even Direct Services that are
given to students in special education
it's Transportation One specialized
transportation for a student can cost
around eighty five thousand dollars and
that's about average
is that for a student who's receiving
education out of District not
necessarily so if there are barriers to
a student
to get to school and they have an IEP we
are required by a lot of transport them
to school so there there is a mix yes it
is for students who go to out of
District placements but it is also for
students who attend the local Lea
um
and okay hold on
um I want to read a rule here rule 45
that for the house rules here
and it says reporting a bills committee
reports retain bills interim study as a
second year report
printing uh of committee reports and
amendments part one are in compliance
with this all bills in The Possession
committee shall be reported out by the
date specified in rule 66 when one of
the following recommendations we can
either recommend ought to pass
ought to pass with amendment inexpedient
to legislate refer for interim study or
recommend but the past uh uh let's see
recommend but to be laid on the table
because of funding
this is a funding bill so if we
recommend go forward this is going to be
put on the table
basically it's dead
or you can interim study it and there
would be a study conducted
but because of the budget already being
defined there will be no additional
dollars
in the biennium we just passed the
so
you know we have two options here one to
study it as this committee right here
or to recommend not to pass and then
it's going to be put on the table
or we go with representative Heath spill
setting up a commission study to really
properly look at not just catastrophic
AIDs that this bill is but look at the
whole thing differentiated a how many
kids about 30 000 special ed kids
twenty one hundred dollars a piece
that's you're close to 60 million
dollars
plus adding on the 30 million dollars so
we're up close to 95 million 100 million
dollars for a special ed here
it seems reasonable to me that we're not
going to be able to get something done
in this committee right here
we've studied this bill before and I
never got the data back from when we
asked we tried to drop it down not the
one and a half but the two and a half
we never got the data back then
so
I think it needs to step it up a notch
from committee to commission and really
look at overhauling how we're funding
special education in the state of New
Hampshire
yeah turkey is the third clarification
all of it hope is one of the co-sponsors
of you as a chair
I thought the intent of this bill I may
be I may be wrong but I thought the
incent of this bill was to
um reduce the catastrophic impact
not the
end of the annual special ed impact on
budgets I thought this was to to reduce
the the times for the catastrophic
impact
stop in that point right there if you're
a small different District like a
Paramount
you're you're hammering them more
because by reducing to one half we've
just been told the number of kids
qualifying for cat Aid is going to
increase
that limited pot of money is going to
then be spread over all those kids and
the amount that Paramount would have
gotten it's going to be less
and they don't have a reserve fund and
they don't have other special ed kids
which are going to capture any funding
based upon differentiated Aid which is
limited amount of money to begin with
the best pay if I may isn't that based
on the number in the budget right now
yeah okay so let's assume that there's
no number so some of the intent the
intent of the bill if I understand it
correctly and you may hear the
corresponsible I may be wrong but
thought the attemptive bill was to set a
number one and a half to two and a half
move down to three and a half times the
catastrophic eight so that that
districts have a better chance of
surviving after their school budget set
and they have something to come in so
they aren't paying waiting for three and
a half it's a two number or a two and a
half number
I wasn't talking about well you can do
that if you're going to just set a
policy and put an effective date of
2026. or something
that that is something that's a step
forward this is year four and we don't
we still live in the same goal Rick this
is my point the only problem in special
ed okay in terms of funding I don't
think it is
so but this is that may not be the only
problem especially I would concur with
you however this is a problem as one we
can address
policy wise
so respectfully I don't think it's
either or
we could support this bill
we have the language you just noted that
it can't go into place until funding
is appropriated and we could also
support Mary Hughes study commission to
look at the whole broad picture
for instance looking at
the reality that the state can
if they don't fund enough not
supply all the CATE at whatever formula
is being used they Supply whatever
I think we should do both
I also want to note that it's not quite
accurate to think that this is only
affecting the small towns and gosh knows
I really want to help the small towns
but actually it's all the towns
23 percent of Education funding is
Special Ed
across the board Portsmouth is 21
they're not a little small poor town
it's everywhere
so we're
we're going to have the little towns but
yeah yeah I I agree this the system has
to be fixed but do we have command of
everything we need to for example if
it's going to be three and a half eight
and a half whatever
that money's being used to support a
what do we do in terms of auditing or
going out there and evaluating ensure
those IEP goals are being followed at
that residential placement let's say in
Massachusetts
or in Tennessee
so the responsibility Still Remains with
that residential Lea so if the student
comes from Pembroke and they go to
Tennessee to go to school it's still the
responsibility of where that child
resides which is in Pembroke to ensure
yeah that's a
great on paper
but
you know the visitation never happens
yes represent a hall thank you I'm
finding it hard to believe that this
data can't be
can't be collected right I mean can can
you make can you can the doe ask special
ed directors individual
directors to come up with this
information I mean to sit back and
always never know what that number is an
estimate or something we other than what
you just gave us which is not really
accurate probably unless um there was
something unless there was something
within that language I have no authority
to ask them for that because I'm not
using it for anything I have the
authority to ask them when they apply
for special education Aid because I'm
reimbursing them for that but I don't
have the authority to say you need to
give me each individual child's costs I
there's nothing there's no language that
says that I can ask them for that and it
would I think it would take them a while
to do that as Jeff said it's not
something that she does
um you'd have to go and we do it this is
what we do for special education Aid we
it takes us from July until December and
we go through every single IEP and every
single service and correlate it to every
single invoice there are four people we
typically hire four people to do this
and that's their job for those six
months is to go through and correlate it
so is this number never going to be
known unless it goes into effect and
then we'll find out
authority to ask for it so unless it
went into effect then they were then I
could ask them for it when they applied
I don't have the authority to ask them
for that and it's I think it would be
cost prohibitive to try to get them to
to do that to submit to us
I think the closest thing that is
readily available like uh was alluded to
before was the doe 25
um so the special education directors
across the street estate every year
optionally fill out what we call the
special ed cost survey and so we review
our doe 25 which gives us a whole cost
of special education and we answer a
variety of questions that ask number of
students those kind of things
um and there's some formulas they put
into these questionnaires and it comes
out it spits out what our average cost
for special education is each of those
districts the survey is optional we
don't have to fill it out but there is a
mechanism in place to gather some
baseline data but it won't give you
per cost per kit it gives you an average
but there is a survey that exists I know
I have filled it out every year for the
last four years
so and that will go back to the average
cost that we have been asked about we
could give you the average cost but it's
not going to give you that higher that
low or individual student possible
okay thank you
um so
um
just a just a couple thoughts on the
conversation that we've been having here
too
I I think it probably would I mean if if
a bill like this were to pass
I think um that's a that's an
alternative to prorating all the
payments in districts by a substantial
amount because obviously there's more
pupils involved that the department
could go to Detroit fiscal committee and
request
um
for that print so I mean there are I
think Provisions in in state government
to um you know where where where money
that's that
that was not appropriated during a
during a budget year can be used to
handle new expense that that's that's
what they call the black hole in funding
well the the the fiscal committee and
the number of departments all over the
state
know they're going to need X number of
dollars but their budget's only funded
at this level they say oh don't worry
I'll just go back and say I've spent
more than this and I need this and and
whether they get or not so I wanted to
comment on that but I also wanted to
comment that um that if we um you know I
think it would be a loss for the uh from
State
um and the lost opportunity if we were
to itl 577 and not at least use it for a
vehicle to require the department to um
to to determine what the cost would be
above 1X one and a half to two and a
half three three and a half
um so that we sort of get those those
break points and I think we could
probably do that that's an amendment to
uh to this bill that is something that
would would um would make a study
commission even that much more effective
having having those those numbers
available
you know I agree with you on that
representative that during the month of
July and August we weren't allowed to
meet
so here we are in the month of September
dealing with this heady issue which we
know was a tough one and talking about
gathering information you're not going
to get it you're not going to get it in
just three weeks time four weeks time
we've been asking for Teacher shortage
we're trying to get figures on
certification and Steve's lucky be able
to get you know the first request he got
he got 20 percent of the districts to
respond
six months later it gotten up to 56
percent
and that's where it lays
and we had the same thing when it came
to the Emergency Management plans
operation plans
when we sat in there we're trying to
Dole out the 40 million dollars so 30
point something million dollars
we asked how many have submitted
20 and ultimate sure I think you know if
we were to amend this bill to collect
that data yeah we could put a carrot on
it too yeah well you got to have the
carrot and the only thing you can't
compensate the districts and the
department for uh for doing the work
and this is why I think that
representative he has money attached to
her commission study that to get the
survey data data you know I I wonder how
many surveys are sent out monthly or
requests for information of these school
districts that are understaffed to begin
with
and you they're sitting trying to
process this stuff and you're
understaffed
um eighty percent of the salaries are
they're paid by federal dollars At Doe
and so you know I I think that this is a
real stretch it's beyond just normal
operating procedure and Gathering of
data especially when we send the stuff
out and we have folks that are not
responding
I get that I get that constantly from Mr
Appleby I get it constantly from Caitlin
Davis
and and it takes a number of Yanks to
try to get the information brought back
in I bet you get the same thing things
don't come in a timely basis but but
this bill if it were Amendment could be
interact passed on January 4th
signed shortly there are certainly
months in advance of you're in
representative
yeah you're not gonna and have that
information available to a commission at
the time it starts
does this sound like something
your eyes are with an interim study and
do it it's a in-room study that way you
can do it now
you'll begin
as we said most districts are very short
on staff I think it would be extremely
difficult to get from them not that they
wouldn't want to provide it knowing that
they could get more funding I just think
that it goes back to we have four people
do this for six months for 700 kids
you're asking the entire state to do it
for 30 000 kids in every single IEP so I
just like I don't know how long it would
take I don't know if they have the
manpower to do it I I think they would
be they would understand why you're
asking for it but it's just that's a
huge
learning data anywhere perhaps
that compares New Hampshire special ed
costs with the cost of special ed
elsewhere in the country
I'm sure there is I could try to find
something for you
I'm not trying to make more work that's
actually easier because I could just
reach out to one of my ta providers and
say do you have average cost of special
education across the states
we could get that through the education
Commission in the state yeah I mean I
think would perhaps be worthwhile if
if there's not a large disparity between
states
then maybe it's at least some
perspective on what this bill would cost
us to look at you know how is this
happening elsewhere
and I do just want to say I fully
support representative lunos
perspective that if we can figure out
some viable way
to start getting data
for New Hampshire sooner and respecting
that you you and your staffs do not have
time to do that in the schools they're
already trying to do more than enough
but the commission's not if the
commission gets formed what is it going
to work with if it doesn't have any data
they're going to get the data why wait
so who's going by what Authority are we
yeah passing law which is not until
accidental Amendment
when January 1st
so that's to get started it'll go to a
second committee
I guarantee it won't make it out of that
because this this bill has gone to that
second committee at two and a half times
the bill that's written here right we're
talking to collect data right
collect data yeah okay
so we amend this bill to replace the
content of the bill
with a request to collect the data that
would help us
determine how to proceed us or the
commission
no that'd be strictly policy
well there could be there could be a an
appropriation yeah just to collect the
data universe
yes
comparing Apple
's because
from you that
school has this much that they have to
fulfill and one person fulfills it but
it's hard to divide it up into what
portion of their salary is being devoted
to that so we're not we're at we're
asking for how much does it cost to do
this student and you're paying for it by
it's a part of this and it's a part of
this teacher and part of this Aid and a
part of this thing so I'm not sure how
to draw those two numbers together
because we're asking for people to do
not just math but to change it and to
and to put it into different form to get
it and they're usually used to reporting
it
personally that's why I haven't
collected the individual student data
and I've gone with a district average
I I mean I could look up and tell you
what my average cost per pupil is we
identified people in each one of my
schools because I calculated it out
doing just that but I didn't break it
down per hour per kid because that would
be a whole different thing and it isn't
necessarily the scope of what I was
looking for and so the problem is we're
trying to look at those kind of numbers
by one and a half times x but we don't
know what x is exactly
okay all right well okay I got a
question yes so so the question that I
have of listening to all this is
when you when you
when a school district makes a request
for reimbursement
do they make a request on a specific is
their title is there a label is there
how do you know what you're going to be
paying for there's got to be some kind
of a uh an invoice or something that
says okay this student is going to this
residential school it's costing this
amount this is the request so so what
are you actually reimbursing
so we have so the districts all know
about special education Aid and their
student has to reach the three and a
half times the estimated cost per pupil
and so that estimated cost for pupil is
for the whole state and when we're
talking about the doe 25 that's where it
comes from and so anything over so they
put all this information into nessus and
then we have a uh
um behind the scenes it formulates it
for us and so our district will upload
their invoices and then we're in our
review process now and we're reviewing
all the district's costs to make sure
that's in the IEP and allowable and then
we refund them come January 1st so what
is a cost so they they submit costs for
um the tuition for a residential
placement for transportation for speech
services for a paraprofessional for
anything like anything like that that is
going to bring them up over the cap if
they're in if they go to another school
and they may submit for for the teacher
cost if they're going to a charter
school sometimes they submit for the
teacher cost because you're splitting
the cost of that teacher between five
special education students as you
provide services to them so it's
anything that is provided to a child for
services including tuition is something
that's submitted to us they need to
submit the invoices and then as as Lisa
said they take we take the invoice and
then we look at the child's IEP and say
yes this says that they got speech three
times a week and yep their IEP says they
receive speech three times a week yes we
can reimburse you for that and that
child has an identification number
correct so it's not it's not specific
it's not specific to any name it's just
to an ID number right the system does
have their names in it yes the system
has the names but from an identification
standpoint you've got the number rather
than the name
we have all so we have all of that
um typically what they put on an invoice
is a student's sacid number yes thank
you okay thank you so but so if you have
Mill Myler is as has an IEP and in that
IEP it says this is what he has to do
yeah it says and also says
um how much teacher luno is spending
with that teacher how much that is uh is
is cost a cost for that so you you do
have that information on an individual
so by individuals students only for the
students that they are submitting for
special education Aid so if they're not
going to submit if if if she has a
student who she knows is only going to
get two units of speech each week she's
going to say nope they're not going to
meet special education Aid cap I'm not
even going to put their invoices in I'm
I'm just gonna we're just gonna pay that
cost because I know it's not going to
reach cap so we never see that invoice I
have the IEP I have the services I never
get an invoice from Jess to say please
pay me for this because she knows she's
not going to reach the cap with that
student
so we only get the students that they
that's the districts know that they're
either going to meet cap or come very
close to cap so that they can ask for
reimbursement
foreign
how do you break down the expenses that
are separated between HHS and doe on
these residential placements so we pay
the education portion and then they pay
the residential portion now
what about room and board if they're
placed by DHHS
if they're placed by DHHS yes
and you have that explained to me a
little boy if we have in my district a
child that's going to receive
a placement in a a school that's not in
the district for a special IEP needs
and going to have to be there 24 7.
how's that break down in terms of shared
costs there is no shared cost if it's
not if they are not involved with DHHS
is not a shared cost it is just the cost
of the district so that's all private
District yep
and and uh and you do an do you do an
audit of the accounting practice that
you know to ensure that they're saying
this is going to cost 186 thousand
dollars per year
how do you ensure that the expenses and
what they're submitting to you are
associated with the IEP so we approve
rates for special educa for private
providers of special education each year
they submit their budgets to us and
their audits to us of the costs that
they've put in
um over the year so they have the whole
form that they fill out that puts in all
of the costs that they spent and then we
use that to determine their rate each
year
yes representative Hall thank you is
there a software that you don't own but
is it a software that would sort this
stuff out there's got to be right there
would the you've never heard of any
software this is with software
um so this is with our New Hampshire
special education information system we
call it nessus right so all of um all
but five districts use nesses to put
their IEPs into that and then the other
five districts have to put in um a
certain number of data points and they
have to put in more information if
they're putting in for special education
Aid so they have all of the information
regarding the child in the system and
then they submit their invoices through
the same system and it and we calculate
the system calculates what their cap is
but then we go back and confirm that yes
this invoice matches this IEP and we're
actually paying for what we're supposed
to pay for so the system does it does
track it and pull it all in but then you
have to go back and you have to confirm
because sometimes they'll put in for a
paraprofessional and um it's five hours
a day and sometimes the IEP only says
two hours a day and we can't pay for
that extra three hours a day so we could
we go have to go back and correlate the
IEP to the invoice it's just it just
seems like there's got to be something
out there this is so easy I mean I've
written many IEPs and
um I don't know I just find it hard to
believe that there's not a sorting
system but
that would cost money that you don't
have something sure just a question on
the current three and a half times
uh
just ballpark
how many of those youngsters still
percentage-wise are retained in District
versus out of District
oh I have no idea I mean we could look
at it but
I don't know I mean we could look at the
700 kids and see um I would I would say
that most of them are residential or day
placements in an outside facility right
but um I could look at the numbers no
and I only I always say that not to put
you on the spot because
grant that I was there the Conestoga
wagon but when when I was there the the
bulk of the cash drop across were
youngsters who were were placed on a
district
so it did so this is you know so a small
and I'm thinking made a small number of
reset cap in in-house yeah so this is
the youngsters are moving on somewhere
else yeah okay thank you represent dry
so if we can't
fix things by
um moving it from three and a half to
one and a half could we change it by
paying a hundred percent of the people
that are getting
three and a half instead of eighty
percent you know I have the department
I I mean moving it to one and a half
will help them as well I mean yeah but
it also opens it up to a lot more people
I'm just saying if we did that it would
only affect the ones that are the
catastrophic Aid right now it would
still affect the same number of kids
because
um you're they all meet cap and then
from cap until 100 that they pay 20 and
then we pay at 100 percent
and I know I'm not speaking very clearly
so for example if we left it at three
and a half so for last year yep
um it the total was eighty thousand two
cap was 43 000. so
um we would be paying them more than the
30 I mean thousand million than the 30
million we'd be paying them 37 million
instead of 30 million
to them being the district the districts
okay
because we don't if we don't have enough
like what did you say the costs were
this year 80 . 87 so if we go over the
amount of money we have we have 32
million dollars if once everything is
all verified and
um accounted for if we get to the end
and we say all of these costs are 35
million dollars we then have to prorate
it and the district gets less than the
80 percent or the um the 100 over 10
times so it's all based on it's all
based on the total number amount of
money that we have oh
okay kind of like planning your school
budget ahead of time you have this much
money okay
yes
so um
do we have a a way now of of calculating
what the average cost of regular
education is
I would assume so yes I could talk to
Caitlin and find that out yes okay so
that that well isn't that the that's the
cat that's the estimated cost for people
that's the answer of 1100
um the 1100 group right yeah yeah gee I
can remember that from school board days
so
um
and then we could also probably
calculate an average cost additional
cost for special education based on the
group yeah okay
so that we could get without any data
collection yeah great thank you
would that
so 1100 this is from school board
accounting uh is regular education 1200
is special education and 1300 is
something else so you're asking for the
difference between the average cost per
pupil for all students and the average
cost per pupil for special education
right you would want the difference
between the two of those yeah and we
could pull it from the data that's
voluntarily submitted on the doe 25 for
special education okay and we could pull
it from the doe 25 for for all students
no thanks so I think that would be
helpful to really understand what the
what the you know Costa communities are
you know
um for special education which is
clearly the right thing to do providing
special education and is and is mandated
to us under uh state and federal law so
um
you know so and and actually the way the
the way 577 is written is it talks about
the average cost per pupil one and a
half times the average cost per pupil
which includes regular and special
education and um and it would probably
be also good to to look at you know the
administrative because I think the the
all this or whatever it's called if
administrative costs are included or
excluded uh in that so that we really
know what the all-in costs are for um
you know
for educating all of our kids so
pretty expensive you know when you take
the three and a half I'll just take some
ballpark figures say the average cost
twenty thousand dollars a kit
and if you have 700
kids that average all in that is so just
to get the three and a half points yeah
you're gonna be talking 49 million
dollars right right but that 20 000 and
is the average cost of all students
which includes yeah the the you know
um
83-ish percent
regular Ed and 17-ish percent special ed
so that's not a right that 20 000 isn't
an all-in regular
it's not a regular at cost no it's in
all it's a that's an all-in for people
including special education students
yeah you just want to try to verify a
point I think the
um I think I understand where it came
from the 32 million dollars that are
currently in the budget
was that a number that was uh
established and requested by Doe or is
that number that was was uh came through
Finance
I believe it came through Finance we
don't request that amount see Matt can
you tell me what you actually requested
would you requested we don't request an
amount for that when they um just give
us that amount each year
okay so that that's totally on the will
and pleasure of the finance committee
to representative woodcock's
um
most recent questioning
so how similar or different is that 32
million over say the last 10 years has
it changed
yes because
I've been around for a little bit I've
been around for like 23 years and so
um in the doe I'm much older than 23.
so they had at one point taken away
eight million dollars or down to 23
million and we were prorating like 70
percent
um and so then I don't know
not us someone brought it forward and
they put more money in and brought it up
to the 32 million but I don't know how
that all worked we're prorating in many
subject areas Career Technical education
is also prorated uh I can remember it
lower than 70 percent
um and when you come to CTS we're
actually funding around 56 percent
and and so this is across all the fields
right now
can I follow yeah so is the current 32
million the most that it has been yes
but if I understood what you said about
three years I think maybe three years
it's been 30 32 million and we've and we
one year we did 98 but we it's been a
and we've come up we were down really uh
when it was a 23 million I mean 69 68
percent
right going back 10 years ago eight
so what we can do is of course we're
going to have another meeting on this
because this is some committee
come up with some kind of sense of
direction or where we want to go with it
um I I suggest too if you have a chance
to talk with Mary you talk to her about
what she's doing because that's that's a
critical component of trying to get some
work done as far as funding things
properly
yeah
well Mary put it out to me does you know
I said yeah I'll jump right on that
but I don't know who she's who else
anything else that we need from doe
if we're gonna put if we're going to ask
for this and we're going to put some
sort of carrot out there
can you make a ballpark estimate of what
it would cost the school the schools to
come up with the numbers we're asking
for
here we lost my time
ultimately it's going to take me away
from a lot of my other obligations and
duties I'll do it if you he tells me to
do it I'm certainly gonna do it I think
I have a step ahead of the game because
I already have a lot of my numbers but
I'm not sure that everyone else does But
ultimately you'd be it'd be a cost of
time
it's a hard thing to find some of these
districts
like the essay used the co-ops how many
directors do you have and they have one
director and then a whole lot of schools
or towns which are receiving this money
so it's it's a lot of different budgets
you're looking at
um and I do know that having been in the
school district has a principal
administrator this is a bad season to be
putting out another request when you're
just starting schools up and you're
trying to get some of these things going
smoothly
well thank you very much you might let
if you see you're not in the same
building as Caitlyn right oh you are
back you're over there now
congratulations
you might let her know we're looking for
okay is there anything else here we can
it is yeah Escape
not seeing any more discussion here
we'll adjourn this one and we'll come
back
I don't know what I have for time here
I I I don't want to go anywhere until I
I've talked with Caitlin and find out
what we're talking about and some of
this spreadsheet stuff we need to know
that
[Music]
um
okay yeah and I want I think we also
have to really find out what are all the
issues associated the costs associated
with special ed
in the school you know
if you you have special ed being taught
in certain schools all schools
there's equipment there's supplies
there's space there's Administration
equipment
thank you
thank you anything else
okay we'll set a time and call the next
we've gone through this a million times
before
it's so complicated I think Mary he